humanity has never undertaken anything
like sending humans to another planet
so how do humans get ready to go to Mars
or how do they survive this mission last
month we launched a new spacecraft as
part of a reenergized space program that
will send American astronauts to Mars
and in two months to prepare us for
those missions Scott Kelly will begin a
year-long stay in space so good luck
captain
an American astronaut is hours away from
beginning his one-year mission onboard
the International Space Station while
Scott is in space his twin brother
former shuttle commander Mark Kelly will
stay on earth
the brothers perfect subjects to study
the trip to Mars is a long trip seven
months and so we have to understand what
does it mean for an astronaut to be in
orbit for that amount of time
pretty much any system in the body you
can think of is affected from
spaceflight the cardiovascular system is
affected the muscular system is affected
the immune system is affected lots of
things can go wrong the longer you spend
in space frankly we don't have very much
data about exactly what 12 months is
gonna do to Scott's body it's an unknown
and you're basically allowing yourself
to be an experiment it could cost him
his life this mission could cost him his
life
history we're ready for the launch
Cortines we are ready for the launch I'm
a test pilot so I think it's important
to push the envelope her waving goodbye
one last time before they loaded it the
risk factor of this which is high makes
it even more interesting
the engines igniting
ramping up engine deception front
and liftoff the year in space starts now
Kelly Corrigan tom padalka on their way
towards the International Space Station
going to Mars not only will people
become invested in the safety and
well-being of the explorers but also
there's that drama that sense of
suspense as to whether or not they can
survive on a world that they were not
made for